Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to "Getting Over It With Bennett Foddy"
I've calmed down a bit.
Got my drink that I half spilled.
Cheers, y'all!
(*Drinks in English*)
Mmm!
Not gonna put any liquid on the desk of which I am raging.
Everything's fine.
(*It won't be here in a bit >:D*)
So we're gonna make it up this mountain.
I did so much better during the live stream.
(*If you say so*)
I did. I did so much better during the live stream.
(*Right...*)
Well, not like climbing-wise, but just like emotionally-wise.
(*This would have made a good part to edit in previous rage*)
For some reason.
For some reason, and I don't know why.
I really don't. I don't know why.
Ah, that last part there was just the...
Biggest piece of shiiIIIT TO ME. Oh boi.
But, I'm gonna get through this next area.
With lots of... cander...
(**Frankness or sincerity of expression; openness**)
Ooh. OOOOOWaaahh...
And... Less volatile emotions.
(*We'll see about that*)
Which is the keeey to success.
ahhh
Just like that.
OK.
This next part's a bit of a bitch, isn't it?
Eee.
Ho, not it's not!
I got it on lock! Yeahehehea!
Winner, winner, me dinnerherher!
OK.
Alright.
Eeyup.
(*Tactical Bennett Foddy has been deployed*)
Ngh. Shut up.
Shut up.
I don't care.
HUH!
(* :D *)
NOOOOOHOHOHO NOOOOOOooOoooO!!
(*That didn't last long, did it folks?*)
I forgot where the ass of the snowman wahas!
NOOOOOOOOOOOO
(*Chill out there Darth Vader*)
Please tell me I can get through this just fine.
I forgot the ass of the snowman!
I forgot the...
Uee!
EEEuuuu yes!!
OK. It's fine. Haha!
(Laughs despondently)
(Continues to laugh despondently)
I love this gaaaame. I love it. I love it. I love this ga-ha-hame.
(*Stage 1: Denial*)
I love this game.
Shut up!
(*Stage 2: Anger*)
No. Come on! Ah de
oH NOHO COME ON!!!
(*FUN TIME!*)
NO!! WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?!
WHAT WAS THAT, YOU MOONWALKING PIECE OF SHIT?!
YOU MOONWALKING FUCKSHTICK!
I want a, like a scientist to analyze the physics of what the hell just happened,
(*Stage 3: Bargaining (?)*)
When I slid
Ten fucking miles backwards propulsion!
(*Ok I guess we're back to Stage 2*)
Pra -- I was propelled at like the speed of light backwards! (yeah right mark)
I had my hammer in the ground the whole time.
And no traction.
(Instant Replay? Go back to 2:13)
And I get that it's ice and all, but that was...
BWwwhy did that happen?
But that was just a goddamn bullshit.
And this game...
KNOWS IT!
(*Is only game, no hef 2 b med*)
Nahh, goddammit.
I hate this mouse by- cogh-I hate this mouse by the way
I-I-yes
Of course I'm gonna blame the mouse because it's a different
mouse than the one
I had been practicing with FOR 24 HOURS!!
That's how long I've played this game for
And I haven't BEEEEEN-Don't you moonslide
OOOOh don't you moonslide on me
Don't you moonslide
Ohhhh no no no no no not today
Noooooagh
Nope
Alright this is gonna be the one
I say as I carefully platform myself ugh
Okay
HUHUGHHH
Yessss yes yes yes yes yes yes yes baby
(inhale) oooooh yes baby
yeeeeeeeeeeeeEEEEEEEEESSSSS
NOO0oOO0OoOOOO0OoO!!11!11!1
no no no no nohooo no nohoo
Whyyyy
No stop!! STOP!! STOPPP!!!!!!!!
STAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH (*RIP Headphone Users*)
ohh ooh ahh
ahh
ahhhhh
I don't know how that worked
but it diiiid
and I'm hahppy
I'm soooo
Slow down slow dat rooll! FFff---
slow dat roll
I'm so happy
That it did
Because I am a happy camper
and this hampy camper IS GOING TO MARKET!!
okay
alright
I yeee
Okay
Now where iewwsss THATTTTTTTT
NNNNNNNNNNNN
WHYYYYY
(inhale)
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I WAS DOING
(*Yankee Doodleplier*)
YEEEEEAAHHH YEAHH
I'M SLIDING
HERE I GO TO THE BUTT
HERE
NOOOO! STOPP! NOO! GOD!!
(*Woops >:) *)
AGHHHHH (whiny marky baby)
Come onnn you slidy butt bitch!!
You slidy butt bitch!
You slidy butt bitch
Okay
We're back.. again...
Here to get this one.
Yeah
That's easy now.
NNNNNNN
okay
Easy peasy easy peas me easy peas me okay
Now where are you? you butt bitch?
V        Slidy Butt Right Here Markimoo!
No come on come on come on slidy butt, sldy butt, give me that slidy butt! Okay alright
That shouldn't have been that hard
Don't know why it wauuuussss
Hmm okay, don't know why this is so difficult
Don't know why, but I'll try! I'm such a nice GUY!!
NO! NO! NO!
(*STEEEEERIKE THREE!!!*)
Ohhhhh Ahaahagha
WH-WHY? GOD WHY!?? WHY DON'T I GO BUY A MOUSE!??!
OH God why don't I just go buy a fucking new Mouse! I hate this mouse is fukin broken
NOOoo WHAT WAS THAT?!
DID YOU SEE THAT?
(*We all did*)
Did you see the bittily little shitty thrust?
Ahh ha he he he (sad)
wHAT?
WHY IS THAT?!
WHAT. WAS. THAT!
You don't know
why. shauaup
bean?
Shit bag okay alright, HA WOO WHY IS IT SHITTY LITTLE THRUST?!?
(*I honestly wish I could come up with a joke funnier than this moment*)
WHY
WHY IS IT SHITTY LITTLE THRUST?!?
(*I REALLY wish I could come up with a joke funnier than this moment*)
I am NOT fool. I am NOT fool watch. Ha there no
Stop do big boy thrust
Hmm. Oh that was fun and weird why you go million-mile there
Why you million-mile man?
There big boy thrust easy easy easy
(*At this point the humor writes itself, eh?*)
Life is easy when you breezy and... beautiful
(*This video NOT sponsored by Cover Girl*)
Shit, yeah, no not LIF. No to slide
No, no no no no no no no no no
(*Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes Yes*)
WHY WHY WHY WHY DID YOU SEE THAT?!
(*#Mark Loses It#)
GOD FUCKING DUCKING!!! shit (quiet)
Fuckin' shitty little -- OOOH FUCKING -- OH SPIN MY TOP HAT LIKE A FUCKING MAGICIAN
(*Wut?*)
Nuu -- wha, why, why, why, why, why.... why did you do that?
Huh? Huh? Huh? Huh?
Just set down. There we go.
That's good
Good very
good
Hook back on the slippery bitch, but you know was I not I feel like I wasn't doing
NOOOOOOkayyYyy
Yeah, I feel like I wasn't doing the pushy... Offy... I was doing the swing swap
NOO!!
(*STEEEEERIKE FOUR!!!*)
AAHHHH!
(*Foddy is now playing Trololo.mp3*)
WHAT FUCK WHY DID I CHANGE
What I was doing
RIGHT THEN!
WHY DID I CHANGE
Oh shut the fuck up!
Ohh Shut the fuck up!
Why did I change? Why? I had no reason to change what I was doing
I had no reason there was no reason in the world to ah
(mark slamming his mouse)
AHhYes
Shut uuup! Shut up, Shut up, Shut up, Sssshut up -- SHUT UP. SHUT.... UP.
Oh, my god. Are you fucking kidding me?
It's--
*funny music playing in background*
(*Going Down the Road Feeling Fine,
by Cliff Carlisle*)
No! no no no no no why why whaaay?
Why?! God -- I haaate this Moooouse I haaate it sooo muchh!~
I hate it sooOO
muuAAAACHHH!
Everything is fine... Everything is fine.. Everything is fine... Everything is fine... Everything is fine... Everything is fine..
C'mon
No, noh!
(*Everything is NOT fine*)
COME OON WHY IS THAT SO HARD ???
(*Everything is VERY not fine*)
It's a fucking JUMP! It's just a jump! Duh-- [voice crack] DON'T PLAY MUSIC!
It's just a jump,  It's just, It's just a jump!
It's just a FUCKING jump it's it's just a FUCKING jump!
(*I thought it was a hop*)
Oh god, I've made no progress...
(*Oh hey we hit Stage 4: Depression*)
[Despression] I've made no progress...
Oh, come no, please.
I'm so angry, I'm so angry, I'm so angry
*depressed Mark*
No, why-hy Go-ho-hod dammit
You just fucking bounced *mouse squeezing noises*
I hate you... I'm right the-
I'm right fu-cking theeeere !
*whining Mark*
No no no my god
really really really really
(*STEEEEERIKE FIVE!!!*)
really ? *crying and laughing*
*keeps repeating "really" with mouse voice*
*repeats again, laughing and crying*
I don't fucking understand you, and I know it's this mouse. I know it is. I know it's the fucking Mouse
NOOO come on -- NOOAAAAAHAAAHAAAhAAAHaaahaHAAA-
WHAT WAS THAT?!
BAT JUMPSCARE!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
(*Come on other CC person, that the best you got?*)
WhAt ThE fUcK Is ThIs ShIET
No... Come--
I'm right there. No... And it's not a sensitivity thing. I've got the mouse sensitivity low as shit balls
I'm gonna make it lower, shittier balls. It's gonna be so low and shitty, the low shitty balls.
(Men suffer from this in hot port-a-potties)
Oh-- Fuck.. Now I've gotta relearn it!
[ Crying / Laughter] Now I have ta relearn it!
[ Sobbing] I just changed the sensitivity!
and now I HAVE TO RELEARN WHAT I JUST FUCKED UP!
[Inhale] NOOOOOOOOO
Please please please please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please just put me down
Okay, okay, okay
Nuuuuuuu...
There we go there we go there we go there we go there we go yes yes yes
Yes, yes sound the horn of success II Wasi
Don't know why I decide
NO NO OH NO OH NOOoooo
NO! NO! OH NO! OOOH NOOOOOOOOOO!
(*STEEEEERIKE SIX!!!*)
NO! NO! NOHOHOHOHOHO!
NO!
(*Mark is having a conniption*)
NO! NO! NOHOHOHOHOHO!
NO!
(*It'll be Ok Mark*)
NO O O ooOo
(*Cmon Mark, don't beat things up*)
[ Sound of Mark beating up furniture ]
[SLAM] FUCKING NOHOHA!!!
FUCKING NOoo o oo
I broke it. [Sigh] I didn't break it.. I broke my spirit...
No
No, please just let this be a bad dream
(*Nope, 'tis reality good sir*)
Let this be a fucking bad dream. Why was that such a wimpy baby thrust?
No--
(*Strike Seven*)
mmmMMMMMhh, aw--
Okay, I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. That's it for this episode. I can't do this anymore
(Stage 5: Acceptance*)
I can't knowing this oh
I hate you so much!
Bennet Foddy: Abraham Lincoln...
Shut up Abraham Lincoln! I hate you soo muchh! Aghh!
Thank you everybody so much for watching... let me know what you think in the comments below and as always I'll see you fgsergsef;s (in the next video)....
[Weakly] Bye bye!...
*intro music* wah wah wahh